am i sponsored by lyches no
if anything the users who play on mecha
sponsor lee chess
you should join oh really oh do i like
troll join the simul
i would feel bad i did that once to
esserman because i sermon gave like a
100 word symbol
just troll joining the simon join i'll
see if he probably won't accept me
is he streaming oh he is streaming oh
that's nice
wow so i'm actually playing benjamin
bach in the simul
it's 10 15. so he gave himself extra
time i think
yeah he gave himself extra time
maybe do i just play this game and then
raid him after the game finishes
we'll see so this will be a lot more
chill
i i haven't been on like the
the beginner side of the simul what'd
you call the side that
is not giving the simul the recipient
i don't know anyway we're gonna have uh
a queen's gambit declined oh the
challenger yeah
the challenger rather than the simular
or the noob
oh where can i get your london course uh
it should be here yeah this one
right this one
uh this is the first course i ever made
uh yeah it's it's on a site called
iches.net
and actually that link not the greatest
salesperson
oh thank you colin rhodey colin ronnie
with five dollars appreciate that
uh but that link should give you like
the best price
because if you just try and find it
through the normal website it's
it's a bit more expensive
oh spice cup will you play in the spice
cup this month
i saw that's taking place i'm not
playing
no i have no plans of playing over the
word chess anytime soon
what do i even play in this variation
i should have played i should have
played some other opening
i should play the budapest i'll play my
my main line
i don't really know so much theory here
though
yeah but spice cup is usually a
tournament
that attracts a lot of a lot of grand
masters a lot of norm hunters
i'm sure it's going to be smaller this
year
i think hans is playing whoa it's nicer
nikki thanks for reading appreciate that
shout out to nasir i think it was by
nikki though
i know has been streaming a lot more
recently
um people can check her out on twitch
if you're just joining i'm playing
benjamin bach
i'm uh so benjamin bach is also
streaming
and i'm playing in his simul so he's
playing with multiple people at once
he's playing 13 games at once i'm just
playing one game at once
but i'm simulling this game and the
twitch chat
so maybe it's kind of fair
yeah shout out yeah shout out to nace
here
also i think
i think we're all like we're all part of
the st louis family right because
benjamin
benjamin bach is also uh in st louis
um oh this is actually a cool line
because i know there is like upon
sacrifice
i don't know any theory but i have some
big memories
of things getting cool
yeah st louis chess family
you deserve a vip
there we go i sometimes forget like how
many strong players live in st
louis um because i don't see too many
people too often
um but yeah i think in
in a few weeks sometime this month a
splice cup will happen
i think hans is playing so at some point
i'll probably
i'll probably do some kind of irl tennis
stream
with hans and maybe rey and chessweeb
some other chess tennis players too
in the area
queen c2 okay this is maybe already a
new move for me
um i mean mike's going for a pawn
or leaving the king in the center
hmm it's a question if i want to make
things really
spicy
so i have bishop b4
i wonder if this is some kind of prep
too
bishop b4 looks logical
i'm curious what or what white does
against it
because there's basically only a few
options there's 92 but then there's
g2 hanging i could even take
probably queen takes and then take on g2
uh so maybe king f1 would be expected
and then might lose his casting rights
i'd probably have to defend the pawn
but c7 is also hanging so maybe i end up
losing a pawn
oh queen a5 might be a better way of
doing this
yeah with queen a5 there's no queen d2
or queen c3
because bishop b4 if knight d2
okay there's increment that's good if
knight d2 then the pawn's still hanging
and then there's g file action
it's a close call let's play bishop b4
i'm trying to figure out the theory here
i'm sure this is like some kind of
theoretical line
[Music]
oh any big reason why st louis has
specifically
become such a chess city i think uh
yeah nikki answered that question um
thank you rex yeah it's um
we have the saint louis chess club uh
it's been around for
almost a decade over the years has had
a lot of super strong tournaments
usually has us championships
uh sink field cup etc
of course these days everything's taking
place online
um but the the chess club is organizing
the online us championships u.s women's
championships
u.s junior championships and u.s senior
championships
if i'm not mistaken so
um i mean for the past many years i've
gone to
like take photos at these events in
person
but this time around i think i'll just
watch online
oh is the sound okay i'll trust diamond
cutter
i added um i added a noise gate
which maybe people can detect a small
difference
but i think it sounds slightly better
maybe there's no like so noticeable
difference
but as long as it's perfect that's what
matters
thank you vulcan rb
i am thinking about upgrading
microphones in the near future
wow king e2 the lane bomb cloud
so kiki 2 there's some logic to it
it's not the expectation
but the idea is to excavate the rook
from h1 and then play king f1 and
basically fake castle
of course the drawback with this move
wow it's a rain it's another raid from
the wander
wander uh is a scrabble streamer
thanks so much for raining a shout out
to the wanderer
hope you had a good stream
if you're just joining i actually kind
of have to stay focused
oh diamond cutter beat me to it uh so
i'm playing a grand master who's
currently giving a simul
and we're entering a a slightly
complicated position
um but welcome everyone from the
wanderers stream
this is not quite scrabble this is chess
but maybe maybe i'll play some scrabble
later
first first things first what to do
i have two pawns under attack um
i can only save one of them this pawn is
probably more
important and there's this weird move
to pin the bishop actually bishop
a6 looks really appealing
and white could maybe just trade
um
if i play h6 or queen takes c2
rook c8 i'm trapping the queen maybe
bishop takes c7 rook c8
so h6 there's probably rook c1
well i could live with that and just
bishop d6 there
i think i'll just play h6
and see what benjamin is up to
yeah i feel i feel like every time
wanderer raids
i'll have to at least play at least one
scrabble game
maybe after this game because like this
was going to be my last game anyways
so i i have been playing a lot of
scrabble like off stream
and trying to learn some words
well there's so many words out there
and my time is uh is dwindling that's
the thing about simuls
is uh the simul giver can choose to
start with more time
which is completely fair
oh hello to nick nick d
or nick d's
i'll treat the the threes as ease
also nick d's solving with prime thanks
so much
really appreciate that
oh so a cymbal maybe for those confused
anyone can start one but basically
you you enable yourself to play multiple
games at the same time
so we can see the other games here
so he's currently going across each
position
and playing moves he's streaming too
benjamin bach on twitch
i'll give another another shout out
bach twitch wait what's his actual
twitch username though
um i don't want to be caught stream
sniping but i just wanna
oh his twitch username is just benjamin
bach
okay yeah i won't have the stream open i
just had to get his username
i should have my game open it's still
his move
i can also see like who who the other
players are
i guess maybe i'm the strongest i'm the
strongest competition for him
uh there's okay there's a couple other
players above
2000 oh it's in rating order
oh that's nice yeah so these are the
the top row is like the strongest
players
oh he's at my board so he's probably
deliberating what to do
hiya kemma thanks for subbing in tier
one
a3 yeah e3 is a
a very respectable move actually don't
know
is it so respectable because i thought
my plan was anyway bishop
bishop d6 and trade
so i would like to think this move helps
me just accomplish my plan
um and why not
i mean eventually white's gonna like fix
the king issue and
it's gonna be a fight i still have to
develop the pieces too
knight d7 maybe someday c5 if we don't
trade like this
yeah white can build up a center that
then has to be aware of the bishop
the queen has some squares to go to
a pawn [ __ ] army
not sure what that refers to um pawns
are generally short though
oh hey it's shocker the first time
catching
an eric rosenstein welcome to twitch
good to see you every stream i do
there's always
new people joining always nice when they
they say hi in the chat
welcome um
yeah this is different than normal i'm
not used to having like so much downtime
during a game
uh but
it's chill oh he's back yeah anytime the
green
dot appears uh benjamin black returns
e4 oh e4 is probably
very wise because e5 is going to come
with more tempo
oh i have a really cool move or cool
idea let's start with queen h5
an idea okay first of all the bishops
are
having a staring contest assuming
e5 is played it looks like i'm getting
smashed because
only say square is this and i went into
this line have both bishops attacked
of course i can consider a line where i
take on f3
but even cooler is after e5 i don't move
the bishop
i don't even move the other bishop i
play knight c6
which does two things uh it blocks the
queen
but more importantly it threatens a fork
a godly fork of goodness
and then the bishop can't be taken it's
important the
the queen is pinning this knight on f3
um so this line's still probably
playable like we might see e5 knight c6
key f1 i might still be much worse
but at least i have a cool move
wait what do i do after king f1
that could be problematic i could play
g5
and just go insane
yeah i have a bad feeling about this
there's also this uh this is the type of
position i want to look for counter
attacks
this is kind of interesting
but it just gives why the move to defend
oh it's getting sharp
okay let's calculate so knight c6 king
f1
any resources
i'm not seeing anything so promising i
mean i want to make this
this sort of stuff work
not seem like a great execution
if i take immediately i then can't play
knight c6 or queen g4
so that's probably out of the question
unless i want to go for this line
but then takes and i'm just getting
crushed
i think
okay so knight c6 king f1 what's the
worst case scenario
i have to move the bishop and then
bishop e4
oh bishop before i have this move so
maybe i'm holding on
my time i don't want to get too long
time
i mean i can play this and then decide
whether to play this or
maybe this
both moves may be playable there let's
play knight c6
okay i'm in trouble here i might lose
that would be kind of unfortunate if i
i'm the challenger of the simon lose but
uh and all credit goes to
benjamin bach
have you ever played a simul i've given
simuls i've been symbols online
i've given some symbols in person
it's been a while though
i didn't want to take the knight first
because the bishop is arguably
more powerful than the night
i'm trying to follow this threat about
donations
and what is the question
i don't see the original question
but yeah there like with twitch there's
basically three different
revenue streams for the streamer uh
between bits
so actually maybe four
yeah there's probably four between bit
subs
ads and just uh donations
which is usually like just a third party
um like streamlabs
i think the um like for donations
through streamlabs there's less of a
fee like there's just kind of the normal
credit card fee
with bits twitch does take a slightly
larger percentage
but then there's more i guess there's
more like interaction
and there's a bit leaderboard so there's
pros and cons to each
and with ads i haven't really been
running ads lately
i i was experimenting um
it's funny i've done polls in the past
where i asked people if i should run an
ad and usually it's an overwhelming yes
mcnubits says hit me with an ad
so if you're a sub you don't get an ad
when i if i
choose to run an ad but if you're not a
sub
then then you'll get hit with an ad
oh bishop e3 oh i wasn't expecting that
that's a good move though because it
defends and
it gives me less counter play
i'm thinking of doing something insane
just taking the pawn
the sacking of bishop and then taking
and then i'm hitting the knight three
times the knight would be pinned
i would imagine bishop e4 is a critical
line and i have bishop a6
check preventing king f1 this would be
necessary
then the rook's attacked in the end but
i could maybe sack it
play f5 and if takes i have knight d3
a crazy variation like king d2 the
king's running on down the rook
one more time takes takes takes
bishop e4 bishop a6 king e
there's also king d1 okay either
move i play this move so king d1
is not likely because rook da comes with
check and i have knight d3
as a follow-up um
so let's imagine takes takes takes
bishop e4 bishop a6 king e1
i still go for this oh thanks for the 10
bits
and then i guess there's rook here
i have this move
getting a bit sharp i can't wait to see
his reaction
if you play the sax hahaha
i mean i'm kind of obligated to because
if i do this there's this move
oh but then i have this move
[Music]
gonna have to start moving more quickly
too thanks for subbing
people
[Music]
i'm just nervous about this line with
rook d1 one more time
here here here rook d8 rook d1
oh then i have f5 yeah f5 because the
bishop stuck
okay i think there's enough play
let's do it again you can you can watch
his stream if you want to see his
reaction
oh wow so many people saw it work and
maybe visit and like my stream and
youtube channel
oh i have to check you out oh i there is
a thing i was gonna
promote if if you're a twitch affiliate
whisper me um
because there might be some opportunity
that
uh i can i can offer
but thanks for subbing anglo saxon
still don't know how to pronounce that
name appreciate the sub though
also thank you to samak's one subbing
with prime
and ice ice 33
something for two months
do i play oh i didn't hit anyone with an
ad i could hit people with an ad
i would feel bad but that that would
incentivize people to check out
benjamin's stream so maybe that's a good
thing
it's also a way to just if you sit
through it you support
the content so okay 30 seconds
add break just to kill some time i'll
keep answering questions though
hit me with that ad oh i just did
i just did can people oh i could maybe
show it
so this is what my dashboard looks like
so it shows
the remaining time so all the i guess
all the non subs
of 10 more seconds anyway
um there you go
have you ever thought about taking your
stream to youtube youtube has much
larger viewership
etc so i'm sure you know this already
but i put
i put a lot of the i guess vod content
on youtube from twitch
i've explained this in the past but um
oh that's funny he played the move and i
pre-moved but he left the game
so i'm gaining more time which is nice
um yeah as a twitch partner i
i have an agreement where i can't live
stream on other platforms
which for now it's okay with me i mean
it would be cool to experiment with a
youtube live stream
but i mean twitch is more built for live
streaming anyway
and it's nice to keep things organized
so let's play bishop a6
i mean there's really no other move to
consider so i
can't afford trading
that's a cool position it's kind of a
weird sort of gambit type thing
also thank you xpg solving for eight
months
oh i forgot the knights unpinned oh
i mean i can't really do much about it
because my rook's attacked and i take so
if i take then the bishop forks my queen
and rook
so let's play rook t8
my hope is that other games are giving
him problems
which maybe they are oh he's playing
nine so he already won four games
man what a beast i want a grand master
um now the t2 i just took a
main mainly a sip of air
ah a finney fini got a stafford today
and sacked three pieces
did you win i assume you won if it was
if it was a sack
or three sacks it probably
indicates a win if it was blundering
three pieces that indicates a loss
i could cyber like this i had a bug a
while ago but i think it was fixed
with like the page not refreshing
um but i also
like i'm i try and be careful
um the thing about simuls
they're enjoyable for the players who
play them
or who play in them but they're not as
enjoyable for
just people watching because it can be
hard to follow
because the games keep switching um i'll
consider it
i have to take the knight so i'm
threatening to do this and then this
maybe like yeah assignment every month
or something
uh perhaps i can turn it into a thing
this is actually really interesting
because like the king has no
moves i could just play f5 here
threatening
f4 oh there's bishop e2
the bishop e2 is maybe a saving resource
there's also queen c3
man the queen c3 okay so there's a few
things to think about
in very little time
i think i'll start with f5
and this is a fun game after the opening
i've
i'll admit that i thought it was going
to be kind of a more dry
grinding positional game but this is i
mean
this is kind of the dubious tactical
gambit that
i always dream of i might just lose
because i'm down material
and yeah white wants to trade queens so
i was thinking queen b5 here
creating the battery some idea rook d3
let's do it going for the
e2 square
oh
i'll admit i did not see that move
coming
and that's a really strong move because
if i trade queens i'm just
losing pretty much
it's a really good move
i'm gonna have to yeah i'm gonna have to
play quick and fights
but thankfully rook d1 i can win the a
pawn
and my bishop's still
doing a good job i mean bishop e2 might
come here
bishop e2 i could take
so bishop b2 i'd take and play f4 we
keep some initiative
and try and chase the bishop around
so i've given simuls in the past and the
like
sometimes the biggest challenge is
dealing with these time scrambles
because if if he has several games where
he's below a minute it's hard to juggle
all of them
without blundering but we'll see what
happens
there is a 15 second increment
uh i have to take i mean i could
consider this
which is interesting
that might actually be if i play this
though there's f3
there should be seven f3 i have f4
i just have to create as much chaos as
possible
bishop c1 there
i think i'll go for this i was just
looking at a line f3
here bishop has a maybe a couple options
but if we imagine bishop c1 i play e5
if queen takes e5 i get the files
so bishop c1 e5 with king f2 i play e4
and i'm just hoping that i have enough
counter play it might just backfire
because i'm
also weakening my own king
but i have to try something
i really gotta play play to the time
advantage
there's another idea rook f5
just to lift somewhere
it probably doesn't do too much
okay goes for bishop f2 that's also
possible the problem
wait the kings moved right yeah the king
moved so
there's no castling curious if he'll
he'll remember that
i think i should just go for e5 like
yolo so i'm attacking a pawn but i would
love for the e file to open
this is probably just a poisonous pawn
oh also i would have queen d2 and again
if for okay one i take the pawn
rook d1 okay so he
he's preparing rook d1
that was probably time for this move
which kind of accepts the rook trade
but what else to do
you can play queen f5 first
and queen f5 could be interesting
because e4 is guaranteed
i'm also preventing bishop d3
let's do it time is value if time is
precious
and valuable
i'm trying to give him no easy decisions
like e4 rook d1 is an easy decision
i guess it's still an easy decision
okay the yolo
philosophy continues
so if we if we trade the e-file actually
opens
that might be my one gateway to
salvation oh
i forgot he could take right away so i
was thinking if we trade brooks first
side rook d7
now it's not the case i could play this
and then e3
wait let's get my move order straight
take first
oh there's a crazy line bishop takes e3
i lose another bishop and then this move
threading made in two two different ways
because both bishops could hang after
queen d2
that's probably what i go for
might objectively be the best chance to
there's also king takes but that's kind
of
that's very counter-intuitive
yeah so here here here and then here
and the queen's out of play and queen d2
is really hard to stop
oh king takes wow maybe he saw that and
realized he's in trouble
i still have this move if he takes i
made in one
the pawn storm is kind of working sort
of
bishop c4 i have bishop d5
and this is exactly what the dream was
to get this monster pawn
if king ever moves this way i pin the
queen to the king
yeah no mercy i feel bad because he's
giving asylum but
oh wait i'm it's not over oh no
am i losing ah
wait ah
it's so complicated i could play bishop
d5
miracle move because otherwise king each
and i lose a bishop
if i if yeah if i lose a bishop i'm down
two bishops
i guess i could well look at this move
if i play this and takes like play king
h8 the queen's pinned
and my queen move moves backwards
let's do that
it's so complicated everything's kind of
hanging
and aligned with each other what is this
position
go eric you can do it oh that's me
i'll try i don't know what's going on
this bishop's still hanging too i'm only
down the bishop here
and my pawn is still so godly
if takes here i mean white white's
getting material
for the queen i think
it's also about the flag yeah so king h8
now so now the bishop removed itself the
queen's actually pinned
if i move here i get pinned so i have to
move
probably kimi chates
i like game oh i'm gonna be winning too
because if takes i take with check wow
what a miracle and i win the bishop
i'll have queen oh maybe it's not over
though because he's gonna try and build
a fortress
maybe i should start with this move
um it is tricky how i
proceed here i mean
that's probably the the simple move take
the bishop
then my queen will still activate white
always has to be concerned about the
pawn promoting
and i can get tempo against this bishop
too
but this is yeah this is kind of the
small issue
is he's going to put the bishop here and
it's not so easy
to crack the position but white's kind
of white has to just wait
and what i might do i might just check
g5 walk the king to b7 to prepare a6b5
that might be one winning
idea or just walk my king
let's start with check to try and walk
my king up the board too
yeah there's probably a few winning
ideas here
also just try and win on time let's
check the other games
or at least his status so he's won six
so far
wow
play g5 this calls for some g5 emotes
good job finney finney and dex pg
oh is he about to flag on all the boards
time is getting low
oh i forgot that was possible i guess i
can just play queen here
idea maybe to put the queen on e1
that's a really difficult position with
this pawn
this pawn used to be an e pawn but now
it's an f
pawn i was going to say
soon to be an f queen but
i probably just resigned to focus on the
other games
that was a cool game um
i mean when i played rook c8 i
i said i've well i was about to say i
feel bad because
he just kind of blundered but i honestly
didn't see this move coming
i was very fortunate to have this move
so that was a really cool game
um i know a slower pace than normal
and i mean i was probably worse at some
point
like the the position is
it's it's like i guess it's my style of
like just dubious
a dubious sacrifice i kind of had to
though because otherwise i just got
smooshed
and then i had to get counter play
and white really never found safety for
the king
win bits nice resource using that b7
bishop
oh thanks so much and thanks down the
finest
for the 100 bits and xpg
yeah this bishop was a god we couldn't
check the uh
at least the opening book because i had
a feeling we were following some
theory oh i'm supposed to take with pawn
huh maybe we stray away from theory
oh no okay as long as there's a there's
a nakamura game
because naka plays this line or has
played this line religiously as black
against queen's gambit oh
but c5 is a move here i need to study
more
um yeah yeah
at this point i would imagine oh
computer approved yeah approves of
white um
really approves the voice but the
turning point i think was around when i
started playing
e4 and then later e3
ah it's already kind of tricky here
so white can take on d8 and then take on
c7
i was gonna play rook d7 here
it's still a tricky position so the king
and rook are a bit misplaced
anyway i don't know if i'll put that on
youtube maybe i will
it's interesting content like joining
and
joining a grand mastery simul as in i am
that was a cool game um
so anyway shout out again to benjamin
bach
uh it's cool that he's he's streaming a
lot more
doing a lot more uh i guess
uh interaction with uh with people
so end game genius
i would have never thought about how to
stay winning after the unexpected bishop
move
oh yeah it's important like a lesson is
whenever your opponent plays a move
that's not expected
you just have to like deal with it you
can't go back in time
and thankfully like i considered my
options
there's a cool idea like the queen so
the queen was pinned
it was unpinned and then it was pinned
again
and i basically provoked my opponent to
pin itself